did you know everything about the force
here's 29 Star Wars facts you probably
don't know it's a crap Alec Guinness
called the Star Wars films fairytale
rubbish despite this he earned two
percent of the gross box office receipts
for the original trilogy making him over
95 million dollars in my experience the
nose of thing is luck
Harrison Ford earned only $2,000 a week
for his role in Episode four and found
all in advance Peter Cushing found his
costume boots so uncomfortable he wore
slippers during many of his scenes and
insisted his feet never be shown the TIE
fighter engine sound is an elephant call
mixed with a car driving on wet pavement
while shooting this scene Mark Hamill
held his breath so long he burst a
blood-vessel on the side of his face
many of the Tatooine sets are still
standing today in the Tunisian desert
Denis Lawson who played wedge antilles
is Ewan McGregor's uncle the blockade
runner was the original design for the
Millennium Falcon the giallo language is
based on a sped-up version of the Zulu
language grito speaks a South American
language called Quechua Oh Yoda species
is never named in the movies the word II
walk is never set out loud in any of the
films the original design of Yoda was a
monkey carrying a cane and wearing a
mask the Bounty Hunter droid ig-88 was
built from recycled film props his head
is a drink dispenser from the Mos Eisley
cantina in an early draft of Jedi
obi-wan and Yoda returned to their
physical bodies to either assist Luke in
his final battle with the Emperor or
join him during the celebration on Endor
no physical clone trooper outfits were
ever produced every Clone Trooper seen
in the prequels is CGI qui-gon
communicator is an altered gillette
sensor accel winds racer according to
Samuel Jackson the words bad
[ __ ] are engraved on the hilt of
his lightsaber during fight scenes and
excited Ewan McGregor kept making
lightsaber sounds Ahmed best who played
Jar Jar Binks can be seen out of
character in the background of this
scene along with Anthony Daniels who
plays c-3po the Galactic Empire symbol
is hidden in this shot of Anakin Anakin
Skywalker meets six of the nine
diagnostic criteria for borderline
personality disorder in an early draft
of Episode four r2d2 speak Standard
English and is actually kind of a jerk
the phrase I have a bad feeling about
this is set at least once in every film
bad feeling about this an island called
knee minted and accept Star Wars coins
as currency eight different people have
played Darth Vader David Prowse James
Earl Jones Bob Anderson Sebastian Shaw
Jake Lloyd Hayden Christensen Matt
Lanter and Matt Lucas and finally a
disco version of the Star Wars theme
became a number-one hit in 1977 how many
facts did you already know